kylo Ren the star wars' equals resident
bad boy and dog cider biter played by
Adam driver has walked a dangerous path
in the force awakens and the last Jedi
and will continue taking what he
believes as rightfully his by whatever
means necessary in the upcoming film the
rise of Skywalker but kylo a need more
than his angsty attitude halted
lightsaber inexplicably high-waist
advanced and the burning desire to
emulate his late grandfather Darth Vader
to get where he wants to go you'll need
a ship a big one a stealth one thanks to
a photo of a yet to be released to rise
of Skywalker toy obtained by Twitter
user Shalini Jade we now know what model
of ship carlo rambled on the rise of
Skywalker and the name seems to offer
some pretty juicy hints about what the
body might get up to in the film here's
your one and only warning friends turn
back now if you don't want to learn any
spoilers for the rights of Skywalker the
girl exactly Jedi mind-trick them out of
your memory as seen on the packaging for
the new kylo Ren Funko pop figure
scheduled to hit shelves on triple force
Friday on October 4th the villain will
get behind the helm of a Thai whisper
and the rise of Skywalker a Thai whisper
let's be a riff on the TIE fighter and
tie interceptors ships both favorites of
the Galactic Empire it features a
spherical black hull assented with the
same shade of red that kylo Ren's
lightsaber glows at four foreboding
round wings what's important to note
about this new information isn't so much
the model name itself but what Thai
whisper suggests about Carlo Ren's
behavior and motives on the rise of
Skywalker specifically whisper implies
that kylo may take a new approach to
battle in the upcoming film in the force
awakens and the last Jedi kylo had no
problem killing resorting to violence
and being about sus bold and brash as
any larger-than-life villain can be but
may all be because such a suit kylo has
become since abandoning his family the
light side of the force and his birth
name ven solo through a line with the
first order or it might be because he's
actively trying to do what he believes
his grandfather would have done in order
to gain some semblance of importance in
any case kylo has been unapologetically
bombastic over the course the last two
Star Wars movies and that's custom a few
things
kylo lost his father at his own hands
and a good chunk of his face and a fight
broke his beloved helmet and his
confidence knocked down a few pegs and
lightsaber doors with Rey and was
finally put in his place by a
jaw-dropping battle against Luke
Skywalker who it turns out have been
force projecting in order to help the
resistance escape from the first order
despite kylos best efforts and in the
face of great adversity the resistance
is growing stronger even with
diminishing number
kylo may very well realize on the rise
of Skywalker and he must be stealthy and
go undetected if he hopes to achieve his
ultimate goal of total galaxy domination
but what exactly will kylo Ren do in the
rights of Skywalker as why does he need
a new ship to get it done isn't his
personal toy silencer and nod to Darth
Vader's own ty advanced ship enough
clear you mind of questions well
according to the description of a new
carlo Mattel Black Series figure he will
continue to quotes search for secrets of
the force from the depths of the
darkside in the rise of Skywalker given
that his tactics have been hit-or-miss
in the past it stands to reason that
Kyle would want to ensure success by
being a little more slightest time
around which is something that is fancy
schmancy souped-up toy silencer can't
exactly do what with other you know
laser cannons and missile launchers and
whatnot whether he'll be successful with
a more stealthy approaches another
question though recent rumors claim that
kylo will ultimately be completely
crushed
by the second act of the rise of
skywalker allegedly the struggles Kyllo
faces in the new movie for lead his late
father Han Solo to appear to him in a
vision delivering him a rousing message
dispersed him to abandon his kylo Ren
persona and turn to the light side of
the force if that actually ends up
happening
we hope kylo ben solo at least gets to
keep his cool new ship the rise of
skywalker flies in the theatres on
December 20th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]